All right, here we go again, another Zoom call for the second of March, 2022.
Just some difficult reminders of our walk here through our difficulties.
And remember who, what we're really here to do and serve God in all things,
even through our perseverance of struggles that we have dealing with.
Also reminder, which I do every time, I do the Zoom call.
And if you do have questions to look on our blog, just go to our website.
And use that little search little thing and you could type in something.
If we don't have anything on that on our website, then certainly ask your liaison.
If you need clarification, you can ask your liaison through an email or schedule an appointment with her or schedule a point with Michelle.
And I, or journalism call and ask the question there.
So lots of different ways to get questions answered.
So excited that we're getting this back office thing done.
I think it's going to be a really huge added benefit.
I started making a whole bunch of frequently asked question videos that go over a lot of detail of different things.
That are most commonly asked on these zoom calls that sometimes we tend to repeat ourselves will be answered on little short little couple of minute videos that could be really easily.
Accessed in that back office when we get that done so that will be nice little addition for everybody I think.
First question.
If you talk about coffee animals, what type, how often what are the benefits?
I did see some information on your website.
Well, that's good because we probably have six or seven blog posts on coffee animals is probably three more pages on coffee animals on our website.
There's plenty of information on coffee animals on our website and a whole bunch of information.
My help my by or in my stop fighting cancer book and my new book.
Oh, by the way, if you want information on detoxification, I have a new book that just came out just a couple of weeks ago called the seven phases of detox.
And that's available as a free download on the website too.
So make sure that you look at that.
That could be beneficial coffee animals again are something that we use.
To the last person that just jumped on I'm going to ask you to unmute yourself because I need you to identify yourself if you will as well because the name is another coming up as staff person so.
Can you unmute yourself the person that I just asked.
Tell me who you are.
Oh, hi, this is Claudia.
Okay, I have you so you.
Okay, I asked another person.
This is Bob again, doctor.
Oh, did you just jump back on again or are you just on a different device?
No, same, same, nothing changed.
I'm just a sister Judy.
I'm the one that wrote the question.
So both of you are coming up as Andy's name.
How crazy is that?
And you will get a good kick out of that and she'll send you a free t-shirt probably.
All right, so I got to meet you again.
I was just curious because I told her last week that Andy, how could you were on twice? She was I wasn't on at all.
I thought what the world's going on with zoom so.
So coffee animals, why would a person do coffee animals? Are they beneficial for everybody?
The answer is yes, they are beneficial for everybody, but not everybody has to do them.
The purpose of doing a coffee animal is to stimulate your parasympathetic nervous system.
Parasympathetics again are extremely important.
Again, go back to the side here and search in this bar parasympathetics.
And you can see a short video that I talk about the balance between sympathetic and parasympathetics.
And if you don't know those two words, you should.
So you don't need to be a neurologist to understand some neurology.
And that's neurology that's really helpful to understand.
So search para P-A-R-R-P-A-R-A sympathetic.
So search that and you'll come up with a page about that.
Well, that's the reason why you would do coffee animals number one reason.
Yes, coffee animals can help if you have some blockage or something.
Well, then I don't need to do it because I have some diarrhea.
Well, still do coffee animals because they'll stimulate your parasympathetics.
The reason why you want to stimulate parasympathetics in short is to stimulate your immune system and your detoxification pathways.
A couple of questions in this slide.
John Ellis water machines, are they good?
So last week we talked about hydrogen water, John Ellis water machine is a type of water machine that hydrogen uses hydrogen to infuse the water.
Yeah, they can be good.
So there's other brands of hydrogen infused water.
Brands of hydrogen machines that you can use as a nasal cannula also.
So not getting the hydrogen through the water, but you're breathing in the hydrogen.
So there can be benefits to there that that's an antioxidant.
You do it to know that it's probably not fast to do that if you're doing chemo, at least within that 48 hour window.
If you're doing chemo, you probably shouldn't do hydrogen or hydrogen water, if you're doing chemo for 48 hours after your chemo infusion.
If you're doing a chemo pill, daily chemo pills, and I would just say, stay four to six hours away from the chemo pill when you do your hydrogen water or your hydrogen.
If I get rashes, I get rashes itchy to the skin, is that a detox reaction? It might detox you too fast.
Not necessarily.
Can it be, yeah, it can be, you can be detoxing through the skin.
That can cause a rash, more likely than that and more likely a histamine reaction.
So there's just too many possibilities, you can get rashes from funguses, you can get rashes from viruses, you can get rashes from histamine, that's the most common type of rash.
But the cause of a histamine reaction can vary, that could, you know, like a poison ivy rash, is a histamine rash rash, but it's because of the oil in the plant of the poison ivy plant.
So, no, I wouldn't say that rashes are detoxifying reaction. It can be, the other reason for rashes with cancer patients is high billy rubin content.
So if you have any sort of blockage in your bile duct, another good reason to do coffee head of us.
You could have elevated billy rubin levels and elevated billy rubin levels will cause itchiness and scratching itching skin, where it can drive you crazy and you can itch to the point and bleeding.
So, you want to get to the bottom of what the cause of the rashes.
Well, it could be different for everybody. So, not an easy question to answer simply.
Next question recently, over the past few weeks, I have occasionally had an uneasy unsettling sensation come over my body, mostly in my chest.
It might be a vibrating sensation, I'm not sure. It's like a wave that lasts for a minute or two.
It comes on slowly and gets stronger and more intense than weaker and fades out.
I guess it has something to do with 5G or EMFs, I may be wrong, any thoughts.
It certainly could. So, you want to start investigating like, okay, is there a certain spot in my house that I get it? Am I close to my phone when I get it?
Am I closer to my smart meter when I get it? Is there, you know, am I close to my Wi-Fi when I get it?
So, how you get exposure to EMFs were all exposed to EMFs, no matter what type of protection you are doing at your home, you're exposed to EMFs, there's no way I'm getting around it.
EMFs are cumulative, the effects of EMFs are cumulative, meaning that if you have your Wi-Fi on, you have your cell phone near you, you're near your smart meter cover, you live in a house with the adjacent walls like a townhouse to your neighbor who has Wi-Fi on the adjacent wall.
And they have their smartphone there and cumulative that cumulative effect can cause symptoms. Some people are more sensitive to EMFs, there's not an exact science why there's some knowledge that certain genetic slip defects can cause a person to be more sensitive to EMFs.
And there's belief that if your phase angle, maybe your cell membrane charge happens to be lower because of other illness, other disease, other things that bring down your cell membrane charge.
If that's the case, you're going to become more sensitive to EMFs, women tend to be more sensitive to EMFs in general than men, and I don't know if it has to do with hormone levels, I don't know if it has to do with simply their weight is typically lower than men.
So it's the cumulative effect on their body weight, they don't have as much resistance against it, but EMFs can cause this very thing.
People with chronic Lyme issues, people with chronic mold issues tend to have this type of sensation quite commonly, and I do know that people with chronic Lyme chronic biotoxin illness are much more sensitive to environmental toxins like EMFs.
So there's not a true science on why I would just say just try to to see if if there's any correlation to a greater level of exposure at different times.
And then there's not a there's not a perfect way to if it is EMFs there's not a perfect way to mitigate that you just have to do the best you can because you're never going to get rid of them.
You just have to do your best to get to put your phone in one of those protective sleeves that we sell turn your phone off that's a huge help turn your Wi-Fi off see if you get less of those sensations.
Can another person's energy affect these allergy results someone came over to my place the morning she did the morning talking about a second person that she did the AKA cheek swab the person was is an energy drain the patient's plants all wilted after the person was there.
And that is how she felt as well when that's kind of sad should the sweet cheek swab after that well, you know, we are going to pick up your energy after that so that it's not that that person's energy interfered with it, but that person's energy dropped your energy down the patient's energy job, surely we're going to be reading at that point.
So it might be good to just get that rechecked well that's really sad your plants all wilted after that person was there and that tells you something I mean we know that just negative energy from a person can just drain and suck the life out of you and certainly demonic spirits do exist and that can be an issue as well.
So that is good thing maybe to get rechecked another question would it be a good idea to do a complete Dutch test to check for hormones this person has breast cancer.
So for anybody on here that doesn't go in a Dutch test is a Dutch test is a dried hormone test that's the best type of test to test for hormones.
So I just made a video on other tests that you could do so if you want that video that's not going to be available to the public so request it through your liaison and they can send you a link to that video I could put it up on here.
For everybody to see it but then you'd have to copy down that link and that would be hard here's the link right here let's actually put the video up there so that's the video so I didn't want to put the video but the video goes over and I'm not going to play it right now because it's about a 20 minute video goes over should I do other tests what other tests to do let me just blow it up because this is a page that I can just talk about.
And the one test that we do Dutch test would fall under functional labs and the Dutch test I put in a bold white because that would be one test that we often do recommend for women that have hormone related cancers.
It's can be beneficial to do that test that we do not recommend that for everybody and the reason why we don't recommend the Dutch test for everybody while I have a positive or positive cancer why don't you recommend that for me because the truth is in all the years doing the Dutch test.
If we're treating that person and treating them with products like dim and high 3C and different things that will reduce quote unquote bad estrogens what do we do the Dutch test it's all within normal range so we don't see a spike of four hydroxy estrogens in the Dutch test you just don't.
I'm very rarely seen that the only times I've seen that is in is in people who didn't have cancer because they weren't treating to pull out negative estrogens now there's more and more information out there, you know, from all sorts of.
of alternative circles about treating your body and taking care of exogenous estrogens we don't want exogenous estrogens we're exposed to them on a daily basis you do everything you can to pull out those exogenous estrogens estrogens that's from your environment.
So more and more people are conscious of that they're being careful of plastics and different things that can pesticides and things that can produce an increase of these bad estrogens so we're not seen as many imbalances as we used to years ago so it's not a test that needs to be done and it's rarely a test that really shows a lot that really changes our treatment plan so but if you.
For curiosity sake of a person wants to get that done you can we can order it for you zero to 300 bucks but if you have triple negative or if you don't have a hormone or if a cancer really is much less need to do that test there's other tests that I talk about in this video like doing a CBC and a complete metabolic panel and doing tumor marker tests that I think are better worth your money now if you can't get and.
If you need this video ask your liaison and they can email it the link to you if you can't get those tests run by your doctor or you don't want to or your insurance doesn't cover it anyhow you we can order those tests to a tumor marker panel for females is about 75 bucks plus the draft fee a CBC complete metabolic panel and the panel that we typically run as.
Is a much more complete metabolic panel it's an expanded metabolic panel it runs depending on what we want to look at about the same one I think it's like 80 bucks and if you want to throw in the whole lipid panel and a complete hormone panel together that's the expanded panel it's about 150 bucks so it's not that expensive and the draw fee if we if you're close to a lab core draw site it's like seven bucks for the blood draw.
So if you want those tests on we can order those tests for you we have no up charge in the test it's just the cost of the test you pay them directly the only cost is going over the test if you have abnormalities that you can understand and you want to go over the test with me or Michelle that there's just the office fee for time going over that.
Next question in this slide is what are the BX programs for on the right machine most of the BX frequencies are in all of your programs because those are standard cancer programs that we do right and put in a lot of your programs but they're just different cancer frequencies you can run them separately if you want they're in the in the general folder.
But again, you know, again, you have limited amount of time and I don't want you to sit in the right 2470 there but it's something you can you can play with some of those general frequencies as well.
Next question i've had 28 pelvic radiation treatments and have developed pretty major blisters ulcers in my vaginal area that are very painful it's excruciated to urinate.
But they hurt with movement they are we being a clear fluid with mix mixed with blood my mom mentioned teabed up teveda silver gel I ordered some but wasn't sure if it's something that I should use while still in treatment.
Like it could interact in a bad way with the radiation no I don't think that would interact in a bad way with the radiation I hope that you spoke to your radiation oncologist because they do have a anti inflammatory cream that they typically recommend with radiation birds who need to communicate that with them.
I don't know who this person is so I haven't communicated with them just came in on an email but I know I believe the creams that they recommend are steroid creams and that's maybe not something that you want to use I don't believe that silver gel or aren't a cut cream or tuberic cream or anything like that will interfere but certainly talk to your radiation oncologist.
Some of the things that I would consider I would definitely use some topical things to get that skin healing think of it as a really, really bad sunburn I would think of alo type products you want to get something as pure as possible maybe even use and get an alo plant slick open the leaf into the pure gel right out there that's probably what maybe one of your best bets.
You want to have a console make sure you call and just talk to me about that too.
I have a lot of hair loss and I have decided to use biocell collagen since I have to be careful about glutamate I was wondering if I could use biocell collagen no I didn't know what biocell collagen was.
So I had to look it up it's a liquid collagen that seemed fine to use of course we're not tested at you but it seemed perfectly fine to use I think that would be just fine how often will I need my right machine frequency reprogrammed great question.
That's a common question actually made a video about this to how often should I get retested how often should I get my right machine reprogrammed the answer to that is is number one if you started with us and you're doing well and you're moving in the right direction that I wouldn't change the right machine frequencies at all.
Number two if you started with us you seem to be doing okay but then now three months later you got another test and you don't feel well and whatever that test was it's showing progression of the cancer then you need to do a cheap swap will test your nutrition will test your right frequency programming but when you send in the cheap swap sheet with your name on it and what you want us to test.
Please ask please check my frequencies and check that you need to make sure you're asking what you want us to recheck because you know your your retest is just based upon time to so if you want us to recheck absolutely everything it takes us you know when I were to do so you're going to have to be charged for that so if you just you just ask what you want to be rechecked so.
If we have some patients that started with us and we have never reprogrammed their right machine we have a lot of patients that that category honestly because they're doing better and it's like why not change it anything.
So it's really if you start to do worse or you know you never really turn the quarter to get ret better then we need to just retweet things re look at things you know that's our promise to you is that we're never going to stop digging.
We're never going to stop looking our promise to you is not that we're going to cure you we don't cure you God's that's that's God's choice so that's God's decision but our promise to you is we're just never going to stop trying to tweak things so understand that the other promise that we have to you is that we're going to try to educate you and teach you that all the things that we know so that you can best take care of yourself.
But we're not going to you know give you a college education either so you have to understand that balance as well so we're not here to.
We're here to give you as much information as we possibly can but there's a balance with that as well.
Next question how do I know if I should do a parasite cleanse what's a good question.
Well the most perfect way to know that if you should do a parasite cleanse is you do a stool sample test for parasites to see if you have parasites that you need to cleanse.
But I say that tongue in cheek because it's still not a perfect way to test because you still could have false negatives on a parasite test.
So we could do kinesiology testing whether you have parasites and then suggest a specific nutrient.
But I'm assuming that the person that asked this question is in a relative state of remission of their cancer and now they're trying to deal with other things I get that that's what we're here for to so if you're in a relative state of remission of your cancer and you're doing really well.
And now you're like hey I need to get rid of this candida issue that I've had for 10 years or I need I think I might have parasites because my gut is whatever your symptoms are.
Well by all means that did it shake so I would say could you just check for this so we get that all the time we got that during cold season could you just check I just feel it really lousy and see if it's the cancer or see if it's a virus.
By all means we can do that as well we can run other functional medicine labs as well if you so desire to do that of course there's that cost that.
i'm sorry there's a couple chats that came in here to whether I didn't see can you take to brick with lumbar osype yes you can take to brick with lumbar osype absolutely and is each recheck swab or write update billable and is it based upon time it takes to test them right absolutely that's what it is usually we charge for one visit usually unless it just gets it.
It's very extensive and then there's going to be that's going to be for two visits so.
And then by oncologist wants me to do a biopsy your thoughts well again a biopsy is going to give them a determination of the cell type of whatever their biopsy so that they will know how to treat it from a standard medicine protocol so.
If you're going to use standards of medicine and you're going to use chemotherapy and radiation or surgery then you have to do a biopsy so if you're if your answer to that is well no i'm not going to do that anyhow well then then then why do the biopsy maybe in your mind you you're just like.
diet of curiosity to know what this new spot is or whatever then that's your choice to but but if if you have any inkling that well if I do that this was cancer that I might do some chemo well then you need to do a biopsy so biopsies carry some inherent risk but all at all depends on how close the tumor is to the surface.
And it depends on where it is so I probably should set up an appointment talk about that to get more details about that.
Where is the cheek swab worksheet it isn't mentioned in my notebook ask them.
And are actually to send that to you that's another reason why we got to get this back office done so you guys will have all these downloadable things it's in everybody's so as we upgrade and update the three read binder you know not everybody has those updates you know so that's what we'll have in the back office as well which will make it nice to have that information i.
I'll have to ask and an Ashley where they have that because I thought that was on the website oh if you order the things on the website you should be getting those worksheets to.
But ask your liaison and they'll email you.
Next question I have a detoxing in the middle of the night while using the right is swelling common to experience in the tumor when using the right.
So understand I just copy and paste these questions right from email so.
Let your I have detoxing in the middle of the night while using the right well how are you defining that detoxing are you having sweats nights sweats at night are you having you know.
To answer what you're defining as detoxing in the middle of the night.
Maybe it's the next piece is swelling common to experience when the tumor in the tuber when using the right.
It can be so in a breast cancer or in so here's the deal so acute swelling is an immune reaction so acute swelling acute inflammation is an immune reaction.
So when your immune system is attacking a cancer let's say we do another CT scan at that time and you're having this huge inflammatory immune attack of the cancer.
You can actually see a CT scan and say wow it was 3.2 centimeters previous and now it's you know 4.3 centimeters it's growing in size and that is truly just what's called a pseudo increase in the tumor it's actually the immune system attacking the cancer so it appears that the cancer is enlarged that would be called swelling around the tumor.
How do you know if you have a pseudo increase of the tumor or a real increase of the tumor.
That's a very difficult question to answer because there is a perfect science with that we don't know that and I often share.
Different experiences that we've had with this where the radiation or some type of scans were done MRI or CT scan and it showed an increase in size but it was actually simply an immune response to the cancer person wasn't having any other signs or symptoms and then over time that dissipated in the tumor shrunk so you can't use just one.
Objective finding whether that be an objective finding of wow it feels larger is that good or bad well we don't know it could feel larger because the immune system is attacking it so you have an increase inflammatory response around the cancer now if it stays larger and continues to get larger and get larger then that's not a good sign but you also correlate that objective finding with other objective and subjective findings too.
Well i'm feeling a lot more tired I don't feel well i have just paid in other spots and my fatigue has increased and well then that correlates to maybe the cancer is growing and it's not enlarged in a pseudo type situation but it's enlarged because the cancer is actually growing.
Other flip side is what my tumor in my in my breast feels a little larger but you know i'm feeling much better my fatigue is gone my nausea is gone you know your other symptoms and symptoms have improved well then you could you correlate that back through a series of differential diagnosis as you're trying to come up with the outcome of what's really going on.
So to answer the question is swelling common to experience in the tumor would use either right yes it is and that's really what we want to take place so we want it immune response to that cancer that's what we're trying to do so just be aware of that that you could get that.
What do you charge for cheek swab we address that earlier we charge based upon time usually it's 15 minutes the cost of the cheek swab itself to if you order that on the store we send that out there's no charge for that but the test is what we charge for that's based on type.
i'm having really bad sweats no reason both day and nights very debilitating where do I start to find out how to fix it be good idea to get some blood work done really bad sweats can be due to hormone imbalance due to cancer growth.
And you we really want to get to the bottom of this you need to make an appointment with the ASAP and we could talk about that we're making a point with your liaison ASAP we can talk about that because we want to get to the bottom of that that is not normal.
Unless you're going through menopause at the same time so that's possibility, but we want to make sure what's going on can we use rapid immune boost without stopping or we have to take a break.
So rapid immune boost is an herbal product by herb farm it's got a kinescia and some other stuff in it so the only perfect answer that is really depends on the person so if the person is in a state of relative remission and you're doing really well and
And your if your last testing rapid immune boost came back for at using it three times a day and you want to decrease it you can choose to decrease it or you can choose to get another cheek swab to get tested for that or you can choose to decrease it remember that pulsing your nutrition when you're at a state of relative remission can be a good thing to so.
So there's no wrong nothing wrong with taking a break or doing what's called nutritional pulsing and we have some blog posts on this where you might you know take the weekend off of your supplements.
You like that and and pulse things a little bit so you might take a week off a month of your supplements so you kind of just get your body kind of reset so that when you start taking those supplements again that you're at your it's really having a greater effect on your immune system now we don't recommend that if you're not in a state of relative remission but if you are there's nothing wrong with doing that.
The other reason why I hesitate on the answer to this question is because rapid immune boost is specific immune boosting nutrition like a condition and such and if the person is is does also have autoimmune issues remember if you have cancer and you have autoimmune disease well your cancer trumps the autoimmune disease and we need to get that under control first but if the cancer is now in relative remission.
And you have an autoimmune disease and you're taking something like rapid immune boost well that's going to be a strong immune stimulation and now your your autoimmune symptoms can get worse so then we want to have a talk about backing off of that or pulsing those specific immune stimulators so specific immune stimulators like vitamin C.
Acadacea cats claw things like that you have to be a little bit more careful with especially if in remission if you have an autoimmune disease also which a lot of people do but things like medicinal mushrooms vitamin D they're immune stimulators but they're really immune modulators so when you needed immune stimulation
because of a growing cancer or something they'll act as an immune stimulator but when the cancer does go into remission and it's slowed down and it stopped then they act more as an immune modulator and they tend not to drive autoimmune disease so that those you don't have to worry as much about.
So it's really the vitamin C it's the Acadacea cats claw kind of things the spits those herbs that could be a more direct immune stimulators that can be more important to pulse or back off of once you're in remission if you have an autoimmune disease.
I hope that's the rest of the last of the questions that were emailed in any other questions yes you have to unmute if you want to speak.
Hi Dr. Connors I was wondering if you could talk about repeated applications of black sav today I was told my doctor believes that we have reached the primary tumor and that we are debulking it which I did not know he believes we should leave the wound open and keep going there's a hard
at the top of the crater there's a hard and tissue area and all the rest of the perimeter of the crater is soft he thinks that applying the sav to that hard area is where the cancer is and he said he wants to feel all the tissue soft do you agree with that and then how how do I keep the crater from healing over if that's the correct thing to do.
The I don't agree with that but there's nothing wrong with him disagree with me.
Because what we have seen is if you stop the application when you have an open wound you have an open opportunity so when you stop the application your body is to start you're starting to heal already so.
You might miss your window to get at that cancer the longer you wait so that's just our opinion and I you know we have had people apply back black sav over and over and over and over again because there's more cancer under there that you can.
You can then you can see so it's not about oh there's a shidey spot I know that's what they teach in the black sav you know little classes and stuff so you need to apply it because it looks like there's a shidey spot there we're talking about microscopic cells here so you can see those.
Yeah if you have a shidey spot that might be an indication that there's a fairly large mass still there but I my feeling is that you apply it again until you get you apply it until you get no reaction.
And you keep applied it until you get no reaction we had one patient with melanoma that he applied it he was the last time I talked to he was on his 13th application and he was on his forearm and he got a size of a silver dollar in the depth of a half a quarter to a half each each time he applied on it.
Wow it was just dried and dried and dried and dried if you would have stopped he would be dead he's still alive because he responded to one of my newsletters a while back I haven't seen it for a couple of years but so he's just before Christmas he applied to thank you one of my newsletters.
So I don't know how many times he did it because the last time I saw it was on number 13.
But he if you would have stopped at any point in time I just think that he probably wouldn't still be with us so I just think that you should keep going as long as you haven't opened it as long as you could hit the cancer you keep going and tell you it's not drawing anymore so maybe just ask your your doctor who's helping you with that you know what their thought is and share that and you know he might have a total difference of opinion.
That may be sold and may be right as well so just use that's my opinion so.
Is one less question do I apply it all over the open wound that has already had the scars come off in addition to the negative is is that the if you do that you've wasted black safe the positive is is that you're not going to have any reaction to the.
To the other open will might be a little irritating but it's not going to be right anything if there's no cancer there so if you can deal with some of the irritation and take some pain medication if you need to I think it's much of your best interest to do that.
So I would yes, I would apply it to the entire open will not just to where you visually think there's still cancer.
All at once you'd have to have an electron microscope to see it so.
Okay, so I can apply a large surface area all at once.
Can and I try to remember the last picture you said did.
Maybe we best to schedule a time with Michelle and she could go over that with you and you could pick areas but still.
Her and I are both an agreement that it's just you don't want to miss an opportunity.
Okay, okay all right i'll talk more details with her thank you.
Okay, the next question was from Beverly.
Yes, Dr. Connor a two questions I did send in the cheek swap swap not too long ago and just just to let you know that but.
But i'm concerned I wrote in earlier about whether or not these sweats i'm having them day and night or know what they're coming from.
I think I probably have to submit that as well for testing and probably have to set up an appointment with you to set up on a point with me tomorrow if you can.
And we'll walk through the different possibilities and maybe get some blood work ordered right away.
Okay, okay, and then there was one other thing, but you know my mind my mind is slipping my mind right now so it'll come back to me by the time i'm able to schedule the time with you.
Okay, make sure you write it down to don't forget.
Oh yeah, I will thank you.
Okay, and Roxanne.
Hi.
So I used frankincense with a fractionated coconut oil on my breast for two years and then I stopped for a year while I was basically in remission so now when I use it I get a rash and itchy and it feels like I'm going to start leaking.
The last time when I was healed I actually did leak quite a bit out my depth.
But i'm just not sure if I should be using it and let it if there's something working out or if it's actually a bad reaction so are you leaking through your dip or are you leaking through a.
No i'm not leaking it all now I did before before I was you know everything tested clear.
So now you're just saying you're just getting a rash I get yeah it feels like it's going to start leaking it feels like there's pressure I want to itch it after a couple days of use.
yeah it's hard you know it's like okay is leaking good if you're doing if you're applying something and doing it's some sort of therapy is leaking good because you're actually getting.
I mean you know some release of some cells you know my first inclination is most likely yes we see that with with colorectal and rectal cancer patients that is the cancer dies you know it has to slough off it's not all going to be carried through the limb system back to the liver and dealt with that way your body is going to try to get rid of it.
So the rash itself concerns me more that it could be causing irritation but that all irritation is bad either so we can certainly test to see if that's better if that's the right thing to do but to me if you're getting a reaction that's more than likely a good thing.
I would if I were you I'd maybe kind of try to bear with it for a little while at least and and you know see what happens if you start to do you get some leakage again that maybe a good thing so.
Okay into that baking dim nobody ever told me to take dim well if it didn't test for you you don't need to necessarily take it so we if we didn't recommend you to take it then you don't need to be taking it i mean it's nothing wrong with taking dim for anybody because we're exposed to bad astrogens in our environment but it's just a matter we're trying to balance out for everybody you know that they're not.
Not taking a zillion supplements either so having that at balance.
The last thing is is when when typically should the rife should you start if you're going to see results when should you start noticing.
You start to objectify because you know if you weren't using the rife you know could you have been at this point be twice as bad as you are now we just don't know so you know it's the results that we want aren't always the results that God and his sovereign plan has or date so we just don't know if the biggest thing as if you feel like you're.
It's a long way that we need to recheck for frequencies and stuff so part of that is yeah we don't want to be governed by feelings.
But we also we pray for discernment and you know i'm saying you as a patient needs to pray for discernment whether this is so should I get this you know.
What's the best thing for me I don't and asking the Lord in your in your quiet time with him that I don't want to be making decisions based on fear but I don't want to be stupid either so should I be should I be doing this again you know I just really believe that what do we go through difficult times like cancer that we've been given a death sentence.
And I know I'm speaking to the choir here but we you know we all think we have this great relationship with God well it's easy to really think that whatever things going great but it's really when things aren't going great that those the truth of that is revealed and don't think that to be a bad thing you know that's how God disciplines us he disciplines all his children and that's how we know.
And that's how we know where his child is that he's revealing to us the areas that we need to work in and work on so i'm actually preaching about this on Sunday oh that's fantastic and so we so we praise God for our trials and our struggles and such because it drives us closer to him and more dependent upon him.
So that's where I want my patients you guys to have that kind of relationships where you could go.
I really need to get retested or no I need to stay the course and trust God where I'm at right now or whatever that decision making processes for you will gladly help you walk through it to have a conversation and we're always here if you feel like God wants you to do and get a retest too so.
Whatever that's your decision so good questions.
Oh we had some questions coming to the chat sorry I had it covered up is black sab topical for only once it is an open wound yes all good question I usually don't answer black sab questions on the zoom because it is very personal and not everybody should be doing black sab and you really need you know very personal.
You know very personalized you know supervision while you're doing black sab the black sab is really for once it all wants to cancer if the cancer opens up not all cancers obviously are going to come to the surface we have used black sab.
And certain cancers that are really close to the surface but this understand the use of black sab brings a whole other complication in that not everybody's ready for so because if the tuber if you have melanoma and you're using black sab on it you are drawing it through that just that layer of that epidermal layer that odor covering of the skin you're drawing it through that.
And it brings issues because it's going to expand the cancer it's going to be very painful usually need pain medication with a melanoma and it could take several weeks for the tumor to come out and like we said earlier you might have to make multiple applications to continue to call the tumor but I think it's far better than surgery for melanomas.
So yes, it has to be open or the skin or it has to be very close to the skin like a skin cancer.
I also emailed in late rife questions i do sorry did not see those let's talk about them positioning in bed shutting down my computer crossing chords etc can these be addressed though let's talk about them right now.
So positioning in the bed so the again the best way you should in my mind that you should use the rife is you should cuddle with the bulb do you have to worry about the chords crossing that the chords are twisted no you don't with the old with the f1 17 is maybe a little bit more of an issue with the f22 that you have you do not need to worry about that.
The only thing that I would say you might want to be where that because if you the chords are all twisted it's going to shorten the chords and that would be the only thing.
Do you another question tied to this is do you need skin to bulb contact the answers no it will go through your undershirt but I frequently put the bulb underneath my undershirt but I don't always do that it's lots of times it'll just lay by my side.
Lots of times i'll be stuggling with it and I'll wake up to go to the bathroom at night and it's by my side that's fine the bulb goes out the treatment goes out a good six to eight to 10 feet but again the closer you are to it the closer it is to your tumor the better so.
I just think that you should just snuggle with it keep it close to your body and get used to that and just be you know prayed before you go to bed lord you let use these frequencies you made everything as a frequency everything know the smallest particles just energy that's vibrating in a frequency use this to stimulate my cancer to stimulate my immune system to kill this cancer I pray in Jesus name just snuggle with your ball.
shutting down your computer I don't think you need to shut down the computer we've tested these computers with e-m-f meters but when you have the computer open you're going to have more e-m-f's coming from the computer itself but if you go out even six inches the e-m-f's dissipate pretty much if once the computer goes to sleep even if you leave it open the e-m-f's go way down.
But I think you should just shut the computer I don't think you need to turn it off because then you need to turn it on and reboot it again so if you just shut the computer it just goes to sleep and then you don't have to worry about that.
the right programs shut down once completed yes the right programs it will run the program out and once the program is done it will just shut down now that the machine itself the toggle switch is still on so that the light will stay on but it won't be admitted any light through the ball once the program is done quite honestly lots of times I'll get up to go to work and by leave my right on because I don't know what I'm doing.
because I just never shut it off and it just times itself out maybe I still have an hour left for the program but at what time I went to bed so it will just time itself out there's not going to hurt anything so besides I won't turn it off lots of times I'll just reach down toggle the machine off so that I don't have to open the program and open the computer at the boardy to do it that way.
So you could just toggle it off on the front of the machine so we will run the course of the program actually if you have your computer connected to your right and you hit once you hit run on the computer it sends the program to the right you could technically disconnect your computer and put it in the other room if you wanted to you're not getting any MFs from the computer if you shot the computer so there's no need to do that so.
You don't need to shut the computer down you could just close the laptop that's what we suggest people do so you're not having to reboot the computer every morning or every night again.
The only reason why you do something like that is for the eMFs for the computer but you know we've tested it with the eMF reader once you close it you're really not getting there's no eMFs coming from it we do suggest though to remember there's a good reminder for everybody you should have your computer in your play mode all the time you should have your Wi-Fi off on your computer so it's not pulling any Wi-Fi from your Wi-Fi.
So there's no reason for you to have your right computer connected the Wi-Fi at any time unless you're updating your frequencies so you should have an airplane mode that will really diminish the amount of eMFs that's coming from your computer.
Next sub-rife program is shot the computer down hard once completed or run others do not is this a side of an issue no it's just your so when you're you're running frequencies through that all but if you leave your computer open and your bulb is fairly close to the computer you'll notice that the computer will go a little wonky.
Like typically you can look at your computer and it's timing down let's say your program is nine hours and 52 minutes and it's timing down the second by second you can watch it if the bulb is pretty close to it it can interfere with that so then people will say oh my gosh it's not timing down correctly or it's timing up or something like that as long as it's running it's running the program don't worry about that these are frequencies and they are going to interfere with your computer.
So but it once you hit run on the computer it's set the program to the right machine and the computer is doing nothing except it's showing you the status of what is running if you keep the computer open but if you have the bulb too close to the computer that status of what the computer is running can get all locked up so because the right works the frequencies are interfering with the computer that's okay that's why we don't suggest you even look at that.
What's the reason for you to look at the time either the timer or the what's going on with your program you're running the program so just hit run close the computer so there's no need to know that there's even see that you don't need the EMS from the computer you left EMS from computers in your cell phone all day long and you're Wi-Fi and everything else so again just like going back to the first question about Wi-Fi and EMS
and EMS we want to try to reduce that and the cumulative effect is just having ill effect on our body bulb is not too close this happens with the foot back to it'll have any more with the foot bath because of the frequencies that you're running I always close to the computer it's not the timer that changes it's the computer shuts down or off so the computer is just shutting down or turning off well maybe that's an issue with the computer
these are at the most expensive computers in the world if it keeps if there's if if it becomes a problem and it's like this is kind of a pain to be turning on the computer each time let us know we'll replace that and send it back so that's a little different thing so no I understand that thank you so if that becomes an issue let us know we'll replace that
sometimes you can have issues with your screens too that's so one of the cheapest things on these computers on the screen so if that becomes an issue let us know to anything else we'll do remember if you want these videos I you know they're all going to be in the back office but that's not going to be for another month so this one is what other tests could I should I do video what else did I make just recently
here's one right here you want any of these let your liaison know that they can send you the the youtube link because you can't see it on our youtube channel
because we don't want them out to the public here's another one it's what's the difference between right hyperthermia and the sauna
um that's a shorter one and easy one to understand they're two completely different tools
um and then I made some other Q&A videos that could help maybe your liaison sent some other ones out
to do here's another one what is it called oh no that was the like the zoom call and if you do want the video of the zoom
calls let your liaison know because we're starting to record them again and that can so if you missed last weeks
I did last weeks and that could be helpful to you as well so all right any other questions we'll call
on a night if you want to record it at this it will be ready tomorrow ask your liaison I will put it
our clinic chat so that they can send it to you too all right thanks you guys know I'll be praying for you all
and um just another reminder to just um you know understand the sovereignty of God and all things in that
um look at through this allowed this to drive you to look at well who else I need to have a stronger
prayer life who else should I be praying for please be praying for us please be praying for all of our
patients praying for other people that have struggles as well and see this as an opportunity to sharpen
that uh that uh character quality as well all right love you all prayed for all of you and we'll see it
next week